en este apartamento de una sola
habitación en moscú los dos televisores
del instructor de fitness oleg están
siempre encendidos puche muchos coches
quiero estar informado tribu o casa tuvo
el miedo que algún idiota apriete un
botón y comienza una guerra mundial
sigue muy presente
y
obtiene todas las noticias de la
televisión estatal rusa que emite
continuamente propaganda del kremlin
ucrania siempre ha sido un país traidor
siempre ha traicionado a todo el mundo
la otan hacia allí lo que quiere o le
hace que eeuu y la otan están provocando
una guerra en ucrania estos son sólo
negocios hacen todo lo posible para que
este negocio de la guerra continúe y que
hay de la acumulación militar rusa en
las fronteras de ucrania que preocupa a
la comunidad internacional
no estoy al tanto de ellos no nos lo
muestran pero está en tierra rusa es
nuestro país y podemos hacer lo que
queramos wave está en el centro de moscú
esta opinión es ampliamente compartida
sé con certeza que nunca hemos llevado a
cabo ninguna acción agresiva nunca rusia
solo se defiende que la culpa es de los
políticos ucranianos vladimir putin está
haciendo lo que puede para ayudar
porque eeuu quiere provocar la guerra
indirectamente ucrania es esencialmente
una vaca lechera bañada en sangre
según la organización independiente de
sondeos de opinión elevada sólo el 4% de
los rusos dice que su país es
responsable de la crisis 50 por ciento
culpa a eeuu y el 16 por ciento a
ucrania
impresentable
es una visión muy simplista del
conflicto estamos nosotros y luego está
el enemigo como llevamos mucho tiempo
hablando de ello todo el mundo está ya
cansado de ello la gente no quiere
entrar en los detalles están satisfechos
con lo poco que ha movido sus prendas
después de haber armado con éxito los
medios de comunicación nacionales el
gobierno ruso puede sentirse seguro de
que la opinión pública está firmemente
de su lado en esta fase crítica de un
conflicto impredecible